annamaria archila was one of the two
women in that confrontation with Senator
flake over Cavanaugh's Supreme Court
nomination she is an activist and
co-found Co executive director of the
Center for popular democracy a liberal
advocacy group based in New York City
annamaria is with us now
good morning good morning when that
elevator door closed with Senator flake
did you think that history might change
I did not think that I thought that the
interaction that we had just had had
touched him and that it had connected
with a seat of perhaps doubt and a sense
of responsibility that that I was hoping
he would seek in this moment of making
such a consequential decision for our
country I had been going to Washington
DC for weeks trying to talk to members
of the Senate about my concerns of you
know nominating Brett commoner to the
Supreme Court because I think that he
stands for the rollback of decades of
progress for women's rights for
communities of color for workers for
immigrants you were opposed to Brett
Kavanaugh even before you heard these
allegations of sexual assault
and I was doing the work of making my
voice heard bringing others to to make
sure that the decision was informed by
the experiences whose of people who
stood to lose so much I don't worry a
Gallagher know each other before I did
not know each other you two met that day
that morning just like fifteen or thirty
minutes before we met and we had time
and we decided let's go to the senator
flakes office it was actually Maria's
idea she was there for the first time
she had never talked to an elected
official
she had never told her story I had just
told my story publicly a few days
earlier I hadn't even told my father and
he hadn't even told her mom hadn't told
her mother we didn't know that about
each other but we went and we stood in
front of his door the the office
his office and and right before he
stepped out of his office we found out
that we saw the statement that came out
that said he was right getting ready to
vote that's what made you so angry so
when we saw him we were having all these
reactions of how can you put how can you
do this we just heard a woman yesterday
dr. Blay seaport pour out her heart and
expose herself to so many attacks to
protect our country she's telling her
story to protect our country until I
stood in front of his office and told my
story to protect my children and the
country they are growing up at Anna
Maria the prosecutor in the case Rachel
Mitchell who we've seen so that this is
basically a he-said she-said case in
this case is even less than that that
these stories are very difficult to
prove what do you say about that I say
to that that the reason why there are
thousands and thousands of women telling
their stories right now and survivors
telling their stories right now is
because we recognize in dr. Ford's
testimony
our own reality our own experiences that
the reason why we don't tell is because
we're not believed the reason why we
don't tell is because we want to protect
the people we love from having to hold
the pain of perhaps not taking not
feeling guilty about not being able to
protect us so that's so you can't submit
details what was the date of when it
happened to me I couldn't tell you but I
can remember and I know that that
experience was mine and I see that in
dr. Court and that's why you said you
didn't want to tell your father because
you didn't want him to hold the pain of
not being able to protect you well
that's right let me ask you about you
wanted the senator flake to be a hero
was he I think senator flake showed that
people who have the responsibility of
making decisions for our country can
actually listen to their conscience and
can actually connect on a human level
the reality is that what we were able to
do in that elevator was established
human connection I connected to him
because he's a father I am a mother this
is not just about us today not just
about the politics of these moment this
is about the lives of the people we love
so much
should say we should say again that
Brett Kavanaugh of course has denied has
denied these allegations are you
encouraged by an FBI investigation I
think the investigation is one important
step the country deserves a process that
all of us can trust I think that we have
seen Brett Kavanaugh enough I believe
that we need to have people in the
Supreme Court who are who are able to
model what it looks like to take
responsibility for your own actions and
what it looks like to begin the repair
process of whatever harm has been caused
and I think he's unable to do that all
right Anna Maria Sheila thank you very
much for joining us today thank you
[Music]